are any of you looking for a video
series that is entertaining as well as
educational are you looking for a
content creator that has invested
thousands of hours into researching one
specific story are you looking for
videos that include chapter by chapter
breakdowns as well as sophisticated
character analysis are all of you
looking for someone that will dive into
the books unlike anyone else has ever
done before
well if that's why you're here then all
I have to say is you've come to the
right place I disagree
I've come to the perfect place the realm
do you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another a Song of Ice and Fire
video well my friends I have finally
decided to take your advice I will be
shifting my focus from the Game of
Thrones TV show over to the Ahsan of Ice
and Fire books this is something that
many of you have been asking me to do
for quite some time I hope that this
video series can be a learning
experience for all of us especially for
those of you who have not read any of
the books that's one of the reasons why
I decided to do this now I know there
are so many of you who would love to
read the books but for whatever reason
you haven't been able to do that yet
what I basically want to do is go
through each of the books chapter by
chapter and explain what is happening in
my opinion or from my perspective even
if you haven't read them I'm sure you
already know the books and the show are
very different from one another let's
keep it real though the books are way
better now if you are someone who has
already read the books over and over
again someone who might even consider
themselves to be an expert then these
videos will not necessarily be for you I
basically just want to give the non book
readers an idea of what is happening in
each of the books now keep in mind I
know nothing if you have been a
subscriber of mine for many years then
you already know I have done videos like
this before I have made videos about
some of my favorite chapters from the
books but I have never done anything
like this before
I really hope all of you join me and
support me during this very long ride so
without further ado how about we get
started let's go ahead and have a look
at book one chapter zero also known as a
game of Thrones prologue the first book
does start off very similar to how the
show's first episode did but as always
the show left out so much information
from the scene we start off out beyond
the wall in the haunted forest
we are first introduced to three men of
the Nights Watch the Nights Watch is a
military order dedicated to guarding the
wall in defending the realms of men from
what lies beyond according to legend the
Nights Watch was found that over 8,000
years ago at the end of the long night
this is when it is said that the others
also known as the White Walkers invaded
Westeros from the lands of always winter
the others were finally defeated by the
Nights Watch during what is known as the
battle for the dawn for nearly 8,000
years the White Walkers were thought to
be extinct but these three men of the
Nights Watch will soon learn in this
chapter that they are back for vengeance
now what you don't learn from watching
this show is these men have been out
here for over a week in the show it
seems as if all of this happened shortly
after they leave Castle black but in the
books they have been writing for nine
days they have been riding north the
northwest and then north again farther
and farther from the wall in search of a
band of wildlings raid errs each day had
been worse than the day before and this
day was the worst of all you will find
out why soon enough the small group of
men from the Nights Watch is led by Sir
way more Royce and that last name should
sound very familiar because he is the
son of Lord yon Royce who actually
escorted his son to the wall on their
way there they did spend the night at
Winterfell which I thought was an
interesting little detail then you have
well he has been in the Nights Watch for
over four years he has won out beyond
the wall over a hundred times therefore
he is considered to be a veteran and
last but not least we have Garrett now
Garrett has the most experience of them
all he has been in the Nights Watch for
over 40 years he's lived at Castle black
and been out beyond the wall for over
half of his life Garrett had actually
lost his ears three toes and one of his
fingers to frostbite and I mentioned
this because you need to remember it for
another chapter
now although sir way more Royce is
leading the mission he has only been in
the Nights Watch for about six months
since he is a knight and he does come
from an ancient house you can see how he
was able to become a ranger immediately
he definitely isn't afraid to flex his
muscles either he does not give these
other men any bit of slack these other
men have so much more experience than
way more
but he challenges everything they say he
does not want to go back to Castle black
a failure after his very first mission I
do understand the desire to succeed but
sometimes you should take the advice
from more experienced men unfortunately
first sir way more Royce his decision to
ignore their advice will cost him his
life
in this chapter Garret and will are
frequently expressing their concerns
about the mission they have been out
beyond the wall more times than they can
count yet something about this night has
them very afraid in fact will even says
he has been in the Nights Watch for four
years and he has never been so afraid as
he is now they mention how they feel
like someone or something is watching
them you know that feeling you get when
you're home alone and you hear a noise
and you convince yourself that someone
has broken into your house or when
you're alone walking somewhere at night
and you get that feeling that someone is
right behind you but you don't want to
look back yeah that feeling this is what
Garrett and Will are experiencing all
day they know something bad is about to
happen yet they are unable to prevent it
from happening because way more Royce
refuses to abandon their mission you see
just like we saw in the show well was
the one that discovered the dead
wildlings first he said he found their
campsite only a couple miles away from
where they are now when he got there he
saw eight lifeless bodies in the snow
men and women but no children now in the
TV show the crime scene did look very
different the bodies had been arranged
into a symbol that was left by the White
Walkers but that does not happen in the
books they do not leave any symbols in
fact their bodies were not moved at all
well said it seemed as if some of them
had just fallen from where they were
standing he did not see any blood the
only reason he even knew they were dead
is because he was watching them for a
long time they did not move he said no
man ever lay so still now as I was
saying before Will and Garrett do not
want to be out there any more since the
wildlings they were tracking are now
dead they think it's time they go back
to the wall Garrett even says Lord
Commander Mormont sent us out here to
track them down and that's what we did
Garrett thinks it's the cold weather
that killed the wildlings he should know
since he has the experience
also will said he did not see any blood
there for them dying by the cold weather
does seem reasonable
but that's until way more Royce reminds
them about the wall he says it's not
cold enough for that to happen because
the wall is weeping
which basically means the weather isn't
below freezing because water is running
down the wall it's melting he also
reminds them these dead wildlings are
wearing leather and fur they also have
shelter in the means to make a fire so
there's no way they froze to death
something else had to have happened in
sir way more Royce wants to investigate
will and Garrard now have no choice but
to follow his commands but if it were up
to them they would already be riding
back to Castle black they know something
bad is about to happen they can feel it
coming in the air tonight just like how
we saw in the show well leads the way
since he was the one who found them when
he returns to where the bodies were his
heart nearly stopped sin his chest
everything looks exactly as it did
before only now the bodies are gone this
obviously makes no sense to well how
could they have moved when they were
dead and even if they were somehow alive
why would they leave behind their
valuable weapons
well notices the axe is still laying in
the snow and he knows the wildlings
would not leave that behind therefore
something very strange is happening now
sir way more Royce definitely isn't
heading back to the wall because he
believes these men are still alive
therefore they have to keep tracking
them down like I said he doesn't want to
go back to Castle black as a failure he
says we will find these men will is
scared out of his mind he has to be
thinking someone better bring me my
brown pants
afterwards way more Roy sends will up
into the tree so he can look for a fire
he thinks they might be close by this is
where things get very interesting this
scene in the books is very different
from the show as Willis climbing up in
the tree he here is way more Roy's
call-out who goes there will could hear
uncertainty in his voice the woods then
gave answer the rustle of leaves the icy
rush of the stream a distant hoot from
us Noel the others however made no sound
this is when well notices some movement
down below he can see different shapes
gliding through the woods white shadows
in the darkness he desperately wanted to
say something to way more Royce down
below but the words were frozen in his
throat serwe Mar begins to ask well
where are you can you see anything now
he suddenly has his sword in his hand
well no sir way mark and feel them
getting closer sir Waymar yells out
answer me why is it getting so cold
finally a shadow emerges from out of the
darkness the White Walkers now standing
directly in front of Sir Royce it's very
tall and hard his old bones its flesh
was the colour of milk the White Walkers
Armour seems to change color as it moves
one second it looked as white as new
fallen snow then the next second it was
as black as a shadow sir way more Royce
his voice began to crack and sound like
a child's as he gave a warning to the
white Walker when he says come no
further he threw the long sable cloak
back over his shoulders so he can free
his arms for battle as he grabs his
sword with both hands the other slid
forward on silent feet in its hand was a
long sword like none that well had ever
seen before
no human meadow had gone into the
forging of that blade somehow we'll also
knew it was the sharpest blade he had
ever seen sharper than any razor now you
have to keep in mind sir way more Royce
is only 18 years old he's only been in
the Nights Watch for six months this is
his very first mission out beyond the
wall and now he's about to face off with
the white Walker something thought to
have been dead for thousands of years as
scared as he may have been way more
Royce does not back down
he stands face to face with the white
Walker and says dance with me then which
also reveals that sir way more Royce has
to have balls made of Valyrian steel way
more then lifts his sword high above his
head his hands began trembling from the
weight of his sword or maybe from the
cold yet in that moment will thought he
was a boy no longer but a man of the
Nights Watch way more is about to show
this veteran he is about that life but
the white Walker suddenly stops this is
when will can see its
eyes he notices how blue they actually
are they are bluer than any humans eyes
a blue that burned like ice the white
Walker fixes his eyes on Waymar sword
that's held high above his head then
several more white walkers begin to
emerge from the darkness two of them
then three four five way more did not
see them or hear them but he must have
felt the cold that came with them well
certainly did well knew that it was his
duty to call out the Waymar to warn him
about the other way walkers surrounding
him but he knew if he did it would give
up his location if he makes a single
sound it will be his death he stayed
silent and watched the white walkers
blade suddenly moves through the air sir
way more met it was steel when the
blades clashed against each other it did
not sound like metal hitting metal it
sounded like an animal screaming for a
few moments way more does hold his own
he is able to check blow after blow
although he has taken steps back after
each one after another flurry of blows
he had to fall back again now what's
interesting is all of the other white
walkers do not interfere at first they
just stand there silently watching
several moments go by again as their
swords continue to clash by now sir way
more is getting very tired whereas the
white Walker seems to be moving with
ease the white Walker does eventually
strike way more right under his arm
causing him to bleed this is when the
white Walker says something in a
language will do not know his voice
sounded like the cracking of ice on a
winter lake the words were mocking so
this is one way more attempts to throw
his Hail Mary he shouts fur robber then
swings the sword with both hands
slashing with all of his weight behind
it the white Walker barely considers
this a challenge only this time when the
blades meet the steel shatters the sound
of the sword breaking echoes throughout
the forest night way more falls down on
his knees now all the White Walkers move
together as if a signal had been given
almost like they are machines that have
been given an order this is very
interesting leading me to believe there
is someone or something commanding
them similar to how we saw in the show
now the night king has yet to be
revealed in the books but I think there
may be one and if he's not the one
controlling all of them then I think it
has to be the children of the forest or
bloodraven but I will get into all of
that later when we examine one of the
chapters that have more evidence for
that so like I said all of the White
Walkers move in on serwe Mart race their
sores all rise and fall simultaneously
slaughtering the man of the Nights Watch
well who is still hiding up in a tree
closes his eyes he can still hear their
voices which now sound like laughter how
scary is that they seem to be enjoying
cutting this man to shreds but after a
while we'll finally opens his eyes again
he notices way Mars body laying facedown
in the snow he finds what is left of his
shattered sword he grabs it with the
intention of taking it back to Castle
black hoping this would prove what
happened he hopes that Garret is still
waiting back where they left the horses
maybe he will know what to make of it
and if not him then surely Lord
Commander Mormont or maester aemon will
make sense of the horrific event however
great as well begins to stand back up so
he can leave he is shocked when he sees
way more Roy staining over him he
immediately notices that way Mars right
eye was now open and it burned blue like
the White Walkers this is when the
Broken Sword falls from wills fingers
then he closes his eyes again the
chapter ends as well feels way more
hands grab him by the throat so as you
can see the scene ends very differently
than it did in his show not only does
way more Royce get slain by the White
Walkers but he is also reanimated by
them and it's not well who flees from
the scene he gets killed by way more
Royce who has now risen as a white old
man Garrett is the one who survives this
attack I think the prologue does do a
great job at giving us readers extra
information that helps advance the
overall story we now know this will not
simply be just a game of Thrones between
the various houses of Westeros now we
know there is this supernatural
underlying threat that could jeopardize
life in the Seven Kingdoms as we know it
the White Walkers are back
and they made a great first impression
that shows they are a force to be
reckoned with the opening scene
essentially sets the tone for the entire
series which is one of the reasons why I
love it so much I think it was an
amazing way to open up a story or
television show for that matter if this
doesn't leave you wanting more then I
don't know what will obviously this is
only a small glimpse of what's to come
later now most of you should know I love
to make a lot of theories about how I
think things will end but I don't want
to start revealing any of that just yet
since this is only an introduction to
the series I will say this though my
theories for how the books end are very
different from what my theories were for
how the show ends for obvious reasons
like I said earlier I will start to get
into that stuff once I get to some of
the other chapters that helps back up
some of my ideas for the end game for
those of you who have not read the books
I hope the video gave you a good idea of
what happens at the beginning of the
game of Thrones book either way I really
hope you all watch the next video I want
to thank everyone for stopping by to
check out this first one I appreciate
that as always have a great day I will
see you very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]